des tests de laboratoire étrangers [Music] qui peuvent être montrés avec votre
produit avec un code QR en fait, c'est donc
très facile et accessible pour nos
clients tant que vous avez plus de 21 ans avec
un ID de vote, vous pouvez entrer et obtenir
tout ce que vous aimez
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle nous voulions la licence était
spécifiquement d'avoir l'opportunité d'
améliorer certaines des circonstances difficiles
impliquées à la fois dans la criminalisation
du cannabis ainsi que d'autres drogues
[Musique]
Je me suis impliqué après avoir rencontré
des personnes qui ont montré  moi les données
sur la façon dont à New York, sous le maire
Bloomberg, nous cassions 50
000 jeunes de couleur par an juste
pour avoir quelques graines de marijuana
sur eux